[Música]
ron de Santi se une oficialmente a la
carrera por la nominación republicana a
la casa blanca el gobernador de Florida
compite por ser el candidato del partido
que se enfrentará a Joe biden en 2024 y
su principal rival es el expresidente
Donald Trump en Florida y protestas en
contra tenemos informe de nuestro
corresponsal
el presidente ecuatoriano Guillermo
lasso defendió su decisión de disolver
la asamblea en una medida conocida como
muerte Cruzada y aseguró que esta acabó
con un capítulo de abuso de poder
ampliamos con nuestro enviado especial
en Colombia el hallazgo de nuevos
elementos brindan Esperanza a los
familiares de los cuatro niños que se
perdieron en la selva tras un accidente
aéreo sin embargo el tiempo se agota y
las autoridades intensifican la búsqueda
de Los menores
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias al
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Estados Unidos el gobernador de Florida
ron de santis Finalmente oficializó su
intención de ser el candidato
republicano a la casa blanca para ello
primero deberá competir en las primarias
del partido tras las cuales se conocerá
Quién será el candidato que enfrentará a
Joe biden en las presidenciales pero se
enfrenta a un fuerte rival el
expresidente Donald Trump quien también
goza de gran apoyo entre los
conservadores el anuncio de The santis
generó protestas en Florida por parte de
quienes rechazan sus políticas anti
derechos desde Miami nuestro
corresponsal alto nivel chi Nos daba
previamente los detalles
el gobernador desde Florida ron de
santies ya oficializado su candidatura a
las primarias por el partido republicano
para ser el candidato de las próximas
elecciones presidenciales de 2024 aquí
en Estados Unidos el sistema de Twitter
donde iba a anunciar su candidatura en
una conversación con
colapsó y numerosos usuarios reportaron
fallas en la plataforma por lo que se
tuvo que retrasar unos 20 minutos sin
embargo minutos antes de que comenzara
el evento de santis había subido un
vídeo en el que denunciaba que las
fronteras de Estados Unidos son un
desastre que el crimen había aumentado
en las ciudades del país y que por culpa
de las políticas de Joe biden las
familias estaban Sufriendo a las
consecuencias económicas decía que debía
prevalecer el sentido común y ponía
Florida como un modelo de éxito que se
puede extrapolar al resto del país el
gobernador llega con un catálogo de
leyes ultraconservadoras que ha aprobado
en las últimas semanas aquí en Florida
como la ley del aborto que de 15 a 6
semanas la ley Para aportar armas en
libremente o la ley antimigrante que
criminaliza con hasta 15 años de prisión
a quienes transporten indocumentados en
los exteriores de este hotel donde
desantis estuvo para participar en la
sesión de Twitter numerosos activistas
se concentraron para protestar por estas
políticas
que consideran que han causado gran
controversia en todo el país ahora
empieza una carrera para las primarias
donde su principal contrincante es el
expresidente Donald Trump que ya lo ha
criticado diciendo que no está en
sintonía con los votantes y que no tiene
un plan de gobierno además las encuestas
tampoco lo favorecen Trump supera de
santis en más de 20 puntos también se
verá las caras con nickie Halley la
exgobernadora de Carolina del Sur con
Tim Scott el primer senador negro de
Estados Unidos en más de un siglo o con
que fue dos veces gobernador de Arkansas
y también en Estados Unidos se cumplió
un año del tiroteo en una escuela
primaria de uba lde en Texas el ataque
perpetrado por un joven de 18 años de
joven 21 muertos de los cuales 19 eran
niños decenas de residentes locales se
reunieron A las afueras de una iglesia y
también en el Memorial dedicado a las
víctimas el presidente Joe biden
aprovechó la fecha para reiterar la
necesidad de un control de armas de
asalto
durante el último año desde lo ocurrido
en ibaldé nuestro país ha experimentado
la asombrosa cantidad de 650 tiroteos
masivos
en general Es difícil decir más de
40.000 muertes debido a la violencia con
armas de fuego no podemos terminar con
esta epidemia Hasta que el congreso
apruebe algunas medidas de seguridad con
armas de fuego con sentido común leyes
para mantener las armas de guerra fuera
de nuestras calles fuera del alcance de
personas peligrosas hasta que los
estados hagan lo mismo
la Casa Blanca se mostró optimista en
medio de las conversaciones sobre el
techo de la deuda con los republicanos
en el congreso durante varias horas
ambas partes sostuvieron este miércoles
una nueva Ronda de negociaciones que
calificaron como productivas y
predijeron que llegarían a un acuerdo
Aunque varias cuestiones Siguen sin
resolverse de no llegar a un consenso
antes del primero de junio el gobierno
podría incurrir en un posible impago
el presidente de Ecuador Guillermo lasso
rindió un informe sobre sus dos años de
gobierno con él defendió su decisión de
disolver la asamblea nacional y convocar
a elecciones anticipadas luego de que
los legisladores debatieran un juicio
político en su contra nuestro enviado
especial Rodrigo sedano tiene los
detalles
el presidente Guillermo lasso ha dado
una típico informe a La Nación en este
auditorio del sur de la ciudad de Quito
un informe que en condiciones normales
se habría dado en la asamblea nacional
cerrada tras el decreto de muerte
Cruzada del propio laso previo al
discurso nos habló el canciller Gustavo
manrique sobre toda la situación vivida
en el país
viviendo un proceso
[Aplausos]
de la forma masiva y más democrática
insisto esto es un tema que lo ha
aceptado la corte constitucional que el
Consejo Nacional ya ha dado fecha para
la inscripción de candidaturas Guillermo
laso criticó los que según él son afanes
golpistas de la oposición antes de dar
paso a sus logros a los logros de su
gobierno en materia educativa y de
sanidad al final de su discurso lazo
dijo que estas próximas elecciones
anticipadas son una muestra de que él no
se aferra al poder y que busca dar al
pueblo ecuatoriano la posibilidad de
decidir sobre Su futuro las urnas no
podemos desconocer los problemas de
inseguridad los problemas económicos la
grave crisis política que generó esta
muerte Cruzada sin embargo creo que el
presidente de la república tiene el
derecho de participar y que los
ciudadanos ratifiquen o no su gestión de
Cara a la elección que se dio en el 2021
y nosotros como consejo nacional
electoral estamos desde hoy ya hemos
convocado a elecciones anticipadas para
elegir al nuevo presidente
vicepresidente de la República y
asambleístas el cne trabajando
contrarreloj pero garantizará todos los
derechos de participación política de
los Ecuatorianos y las ecuatorianas y
así mismo garantiza eficiencia técnica y
sobre todo transparencia con este
anuncio del cne tan Solo quedará una
semana de plazo para la campaña
electoral que tendrá lugar entre el 10 y
el 17 de agosto
vamos a Colombia donde continúa la
búsqueda de cuatro menores de edad
perdidos en la selva tras un accidente
aéreo este miércoles el cuerpo de
búsqueda integrado por militares
instituciones y grupos indígenas
encontró nuevos elementos que los lleva
a pensar que los niños Siguen con vida
Ramiro cueva Barberena nos cuenta más
continúa la búsqueda de los cuatro
menores desaparecidos en la selva de
Colombia luego de que se estrellara el
avión en El que viajaba en el Primero de
Mayo
los rastrillajes encontraron lo que
parecen ser señales positivas luego de
hallar elementos desperdigados como la
tapa de un biberón una zapatilla pequeña
un pañal usado y un refugio improvisado
se inician los registros desde esta
primer evidencia de la aeronave a los
360 grados en el cual Aproximadamente a
noroccidente
420 metros una mujer de la comunidad
evidenció sobre el terreno una tapa de
color rosado y un marco de un celular de
color negro y lo más especial un pañal
utilizado que de acuerdo a la talla
puede ser de nuestro bebé de 11 meses
Christie sin embargo los miembros de la
operación entienden que el tiempo les
podría estar cobrando factura a los
menores lo que han dicho nuestro mayor
es también es que cada día que pasan los
niños se van agotando se van agotando
Eso quiere decir que cada hora cada
instante cada día es un tiempo precioso
para nosotros por eso estamos aquí con
el ejercicio de la minga espiritual la
minga territorial para mirar cómo
avanzamos en este propósito
decenas de militares apoyado por
voluntarios de las comunidades indígenas
cercanas e instituciones civiles y
estatales forman parte de la búsqueda de
estos niños de cuatro nueve y 11 años y
que cargan un bebé de 11 meses y se
abren las interrogantes algunos piensan
que de seguir vivos los menores Podrían
haber sido encontrados por grupos
autóctonos no detectados y estarían Bajo
su cuidado y cerramos con una triste
noticia para el mundo de la música La
muerte de Tina Turner la estrella
estadounidense del rock y del sol
falleció a los 83 años en su residencia
de suris en Suiza con himnos tan
coreados como What Love got to thed y
proud Mary y con una estética
vanguardista la cantante se convirtió en
un icono pop que cautivó los oídos y los
espíritus de todo el planeta
con estas imágenes despedimos este
Informativo en France 24 Gracias por
acompañarnos los invitamos a que
continúen con toda nuestra programación
[Música]